you know a point we've made all week
long a guy who had more rushing yards
last year than dalvin cook
and joe mixon and aaron jones of the
packers who's waiting for his contract
and josh jacobs who was great as a
rookie leonard fournette yeah
free and clear no waiver claims made
by 4 p.m eastern time yesterday chris
i we should have placed something of
value maybe
put it on my first super bowl ring on
right
wager the over under we pegged it at
four and a half we pegged it way
too high the number was zero the over
under should have been 0.5
for the leonard fournette waiver claims
no one wanted that 4.167 million dollar
fully guaranteed contract no one wanted
to inherit leonard fournette sight
unseen right now
as of yesterday there were teams doing
research which tells me somebody is
going to try to sign him
and and as i said yesterday he's better
off
being able to pick his next team he's
got that 4 million plus that he can
pursue from the jaguars the grievance is
still pending i think he's got a much
better argument than people realize
and he can get whatever else he gets
from another team
and keep both he can double dip because
there's no offset
language the rams and the jaguars are
the two teams that don't put offset
language in top 10 contracts that are
fully guaranteed to rookies
so he gets the full 4 million plus and
he gets
whatever it is incentive laden contract
minimum salary
whoever whenever whatever he keeps both
so it works out for him and now we we
see where he's going to go
yeah see i mean i'm shocked i really am
i thought there'd be
a few teams out there obviously that
would try to claim him for that price
tag
i mean when you look at the running back
market and the players that are making
that type of money
they're not in leonard fournette's class
as far as a specimen and a player
so yeah i mean obviously i was wrong
there i'm going to be really interested
to see where he goes i don't think this
will be
a long wait like to me i don't think
this is going to be earl thomas i don't
know how you feel about it
i understand everybody's going to do
their due diligence about
looking behind the scene a little bit
about leonard fournette because i know
it's
it hasn't been perfect but it hasn't
been like you know the guy's like
getting arrested and horrible either so
it's gonna be about that team getting
comfortable with them and then
yeah signing a guy who's you know got
some freak show capability so i i would
imagine here in the next four or five
days
he gets signed i think this is different
than earl thomas and i think this is a
guy that's
of course still in the prime of his
career which adds a lot more value to
the conversation too
so uh i'll certainly be paying attention
to
to the action here as far as leonard
fournette is concerned
well to echo your broader point on earl
thomas that we've mentioned a few times
if earl thomas truly were among the top
half of all safeties in the nfl
he'd already have a job he wouldn't be
waiting
10 days after he was released by the
ravens
leonard fournette is in that
conversation for
the better running backs in the nfl from
a skill standpoint 1152 rushing yards
last year
76 catches for 522 yards on top of it
i mean we're talking about over 1600
yards from scrimmage
for a guy who was playing for a not very
good team exactly right
i i feel like someone should be
very quickly pursuing leonard fournette
and you know
i kind of thought as you were explaining
it maybe teams will wait until we get
through saturday because the roster's
cut to 53 and there's a lot of stuff
going on as teams
but you wait too long somebody else is
going to take him yeah somebody else is
going to nab him right
sorry i was just saying i think but your
point i would think by saturday there's
going to be a lot of clamoring for him
like you i mean
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off there
i thought you're fine but but yeah i
thought
i would i would be worried about that if
you're a team that's really interested
you know here you're gonna get later
into the week where okay teams are
really gonna start to tinker with their
roster now and do some thinking and
yeah i mean that would to me add some
more teams into the conversation where
you'd be risking that if you're a team
that was real serious about it right now
once earl thomas became available we had
quotes from coach after coach after
coach saying we're fine with what we
have
sean mcvay the rams coach is the first
one to say
as to leonard fournette we're fine with
the running backs we have they have
darrell henderson malcolm brown and cam
akers as the three-headed monster and
that's how they've kind of set the tone
the entire training camp and pre-season
although
pre-season this year literally means
before the season begins because there
were no preseason games
but you know look what what a shock
that the rams after getting burned by
the todd gurley contract exactly
have pivoted to a three-man weave at
running back
they don't want another todd gurley
contract they don't want another todd
gurley
sorry fantasy football fans but they're
not going to give you a guy
that has all the rushing yards all the
receiving yards and all the touchdowns
they're not playing that game
because even though that game's fun to
play early on when the bill comes due
that's when it all goes sideways yeah
that's right the bill comes due it comes
sideways
or that guy that you're paying all that
money to gets hurt and all of a sudden
your offense isn't the same like the
rams last year
where wait there was a hole here that
todd gurley used to run for 40 yards
through now he only got 12. oh wait
here's a screen to todd gurley
you know he used to hit his head on the
goal post or 80 yard touchdowns
now he's getting a 30 yard gain you know
so
uh so there's that issue as far as him
being banged up but then if he's not in
there
at all and banged up that changes your
team all the way i mean you know follow
the money that's always a phrase i like
to talk about with
a team's success if the money is not
succeeding and playing well
then usually the team's not playing well
either and
that's what the risk you take with
having one running back be your key
focal point and i think that's why
you've seen teams like belichick
and even a kyle shanahan and things like
that they stay away from the
one guy approach because they don't want
to get stuck having to pay
one guy and formulating their whole
offense around him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports